[Music]
which mean doing the show you know
during your tour books everything you've
lived and shared so much of your
personal life with the world is there a
point where you draw the line and you
say no this is just for me yeah for sure
and we practice a little bit but
especially in my dating life and now
they're you know my dating life was very
public and most everything in my life is
very public the Falls and all and I love
that because I love that I can speak
into those things in other people's
lives and I always want to be real and
vulnerable but I do think there's a
point and like love life or whatever
that you have to establish it for
yourself first and build a firm
foundation it before you share it with
the world I see some family have
questions coming in are you dating
anyone oh my god currently no I'm not
dating into it now okay I can't let you
go without asking about the Brett
Eldredge you do every single interview
I love Brett so much and I love this
song I was so excited to see you in the
video
Brett's amazing and that was so kind he
that shows his heart of really what he
wanted for the video and I was like well
it's a country music video and you know
sometimes they can be a little risque
and he was like no like this is just
like sweet I want it to just be
beautiful when she's telling this sweet
love story of just somebody bring in at
home somebody to mama that they would be
proud of and I was like like wait I'd
love to do it and we had the most fun
that day we just goofed off I don't know
if you know him if you interview he is a
goober like you hilarious there's a
solid dude so now that was like started
a friendship that will hopefully last a
long time okay so I don't want to make
this awkward or anything but when I
interviewed him I totally was like I
think he has a crush on saving no I'm
talking about
now he's the best like he really is the
best guy ever everybody's been asking
this at a holiday light literally the
internet pollute everyone everybody
thinks were named everybody for Danny I
think he's the bed like literally and we
just had so much fun together I think
everybody was like know y'all were
really laughing like nobody really were
just like we really did have a great
time but come on they're girls do golf
okay you complicated so not dating not
dating but not just I know everybody's
gonna strip it yeah a real douche up you
and Brian that's okay I like it how did
you get to meet Edgar boogie that's what
I want yes I love it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]